well I'm joined now by Simon Bowers he's
a reporter for the international
consortium of investigative journalists
and he's written this story for the New
York Times and The Guardian so Simon
leaving to you what do you make of what
you just heard from Mel stride well I
mean I think there are a lot of stock
phrases coming out I do think I do think
the UK was at the vanguard of the OECD
process it definitely put pushed hard
there but you know it's also pulling
into two different directions as are
most countries you know they've got
they've got an eye on keeping hold of
the tax as they can but they've also got
an eye on it in with investment I mean
we were told yesterday by the OECD this
couldn't happen today I mean it really
does sound like companies like Apple
still are running rings around the tax
authorities of various countries well I
would be interested to see the fine
print of how it how the OECD thinks it
couldn't happen today I mean what's
happened with Apple is is apples tax
structure was it exposed in detail in
about 2013 US Senate hearing Ireland
changed the tax rules twice specifically
to target exactly the behaviors that
Apple were to take you on and Apple has
managed to find a new structure that
gives it pretty much the same effective
tax rate look at this graphic here Simon
I mean this was something that you put
up in the New York Times today this is
the sort of money the mats of cash that
have been held overseas by American
companies 236 billion foreign dollar
they're Pfizer Microsoft all household
names own why American companies such
grandmasters us I think someone said of
keeping this sort of cash overseas yeah
well I mean it's a peculiarities of the
US tax code the the the way that the
rules are mesh with the rules for the
rest of the world means that it's it's
quite easy for for US companies to
access very low tax rates overseas but
it's very hard for them to then bring
those profits back to the US without
facing extremely heavy tax rates so
that's why it all gets locked up in in
between and that's a plausible case for
the defense so if US taxes on foreign
profits who weren't so high then they
wouldn't be able to do and
this yes I mean the US tax code is
massively dysfunctional and that you
know Tim Cook says that everyone says
that but it's it's there hasn't been
it's been dysfunctional in such a way
that's actually worked quite well for US
multinationals for many decades and
hence why hasn't been reformed earlier
now what about the position of Jersey in
particular I mean it is really striking
Apple shopped around after Island and it
looked at Bermuda the BVI the Caymans
Guernsey Isle of Man of Jersey though
these are all UK Crown Dependencies or
overseas territories they are and we
know that because of this speaker
documents from the law firm Appleby that
was in these territories you know that
they plumb for Jersey we know that we
don't know exactly why we know that
Apple has some links with the particular
companies have some links with the UK
banking system that might have been a
factor I don't know why Jersey / Isle of
Man or Bermuda or anything I mean in
fairness our Jersey the villains of the
piece here I mean you could say you know
London property is a repository for lots
of ill-gotten gains from all around the
world and you know we don't seem to
worry too much about that no I mean
absolutely I mean Jersey is a zero
corporation tax haven that'sthat's it
does what it says on the tin I mean a
more interesting question perhaps is you
know what what Ireland's role in this is
because these are all still Irish
companies that they're involved here and
the way that Ireland's had changed its
law several times and it's garnered
headlines about the the double Irish tax
avoidance is no more it that looks to be
in question now all right Simon Baris
gotta leave it there good to see you
thanks for coming in